New York city mayor Eric Adams he's a
former cop he has just been accused of
sexually assaulting a
woman 30 years
ago seems like a meaningful detail there
he's accused of sexually assaulting a
woman I obviously believe we should take
all such accusations seriously but hold
on 30 years ago and now the woman is
suing him for $5 million there's a New
York City law it's called the adult
survivors act which is about to expire
that says that essentially you can sue
someone for sexual crimes without any
statute of limitations and all of a
sudden this woman who says Eric Adams
sexually assaulted her in 93 she's
seeking $5
million at the time Adams was a cop the
accuser was also a city worker according
to the New York Post what's my take on
this my take on this is Eric Adams
seriously needs to get the lesson to
stop criticizing Mass migration